it's call of duty time this year it's
developer triarchs turn and they're
rounding off their black ops saga with
number three that lest we forget has
covered a hundred years of military few
views mysterious numbers and gary oldman
according to try out there'll be a 14 to
15 our campaign but who's shooting in
who this time around we got quite a bit
of ground to cover so let's get caught
up on the Intel shortly after the end of
World War two Soviet captain Victor
reznov and his squad are ordered to
track down a dangerous Nazi biochemical
weapon called Nova 6 by Major General
Nikita Dragovich only to be betrayed and
gassed when Dragovich decides that he
wants to see Nova 6 in action for
himself reznov is forced to watch his
companions die a truly painful death and
then he's taken to a Soviet gulag where
he's then imprisoned for 18 years but
it's not all bad because there he meets
CIA operative alex mason now Mason's
locked in the gulag after a failed
attempt to assassinate Fidel Castro he
befriends reznov who helps mesquite and
return to the US under orders from JFK
no less Mason is ordered to locate and
assassinate Dragovich and his cronies
craft chenko and Steiner as they're
trying to use numbers to activate Soviet
sleeper agents to release Nova six in
the u.s. Mason tracks down kravchenko
who then killed himself rather than be
captured upon reuniting with Rezanov
reznov then murder Steiner two down one
to go but and he is the confusing bit
turns out Mason's a little bit of an
unreliable narrator he was actually
brainwashed way back in the gulag by
Dragovich in order to turn him into one
of the aforementioned sleeper agents but
reznov hijack the brainwashing and wide
Mason up to be his perfect revenge at
Ron setting him after Dragovich and his
allies for murdering Rezanov squad all
those years ago Rezanov was actually
dead this whole time and merely a
figment of Mason's imagination after all
this comes to light Mason then snaps out
of the brainwashing and then does the
thing that he was brainwashed to do
anyway by tracking down and killing
Dragovich so now it's the 80s and Mason
is pulled out of retirement for one last
job to track down a Nicaraguan arms
dealer named Raul Mendez who as it turns
out has a vendetta against the West as
his beloved sister was accidentally
killed by woods who happens to be a pile
of Mason
menendez manipulates woods into killing
Mason before slithering off back into
the shadows vowing revenge what a
revenge it is 36 years in the dark
allows him to grow a 1 billion strong
narco terrorist movement who want to
[ __ ] the rich and give to the poor
men in death turns out to be quite the
troublemaker and orchestrates a new cold
war between the US and China Mason's
Navy SEALs son David leads the team to
take him out although it doesn't quite
work out they capture men and des but
that was part of his plan all along he
hacks into the US military's drone fleet
and bombs Los Angeles there are multiple
endings we're different people survive
on whatever but the real crime is that
the avenged sevenfold jam session is not
canon
and from there black ops 3 will pick up
40 years later where the drone attack
has led to the US military coming up
with some insane anti-air weaponry so
all the battles are taking place on the
ground the battle ground as it were
alright so let you get you all caught up
with black ops 3 that comes out later
this week are you still into court or is
it battlefront or bust this year let me
know in the comments section below I'll
come find me on Twitter at least James
games and I'll see you next week